howdy-ho reject nation
I'm the Greg Alba on Instagram and
Twitter this is dat John Humphrey on
Instagram and Twitter social media plugs
guys one of our segments that we
recently started doing is a thing called
trailers revisited we did went together
for Drive I did one with Jordan Ross for
the Iron Man 3 trailer I'll mix it up a
little bit with a very recent movie that
just came out this weekend black panther
this what we like to do in this segment
is determine how accurate is this movie
portrayed in the trailer does it spoil a
lot and I think it kind of does that
we're just gonna watch one trailer
there's a bunch of clips and like other
trailers for this movie yeah this is
gonna be hard for recent stuff cuz
everything gets like a hundred fifty
different definitely things you could
predict happening when I saw Black
Panther because of the clips and
trailers they released online but it's
gonna go off the one official trailer
today before we do that though we wanted
to give a shout out to a video sponsor
that we're really happy to be working
with right now a site called viewer
reviews.com viewer reviews is a new
social platform that determines how well
you that is you I am talking to you well
like a movie based on your taste and the
films you reviewed on the site and
viewer reviews also helps you to connect
with people who share your passion and
taste for movies think of it like a more
personalised Rotten Tomatoes that is
tailored to your and your friends
cinematic taste we just started using
viewer reviews look us up at the real
rejects and I gotta say it's pretty
spot-on so far it's real easy to get
started once you create an account
you'll fill out a couple basic
questionnaires to give this site a you
know sense of your specific tastes and
from there you're ready to start
reviewing movies sharing your tastes and
connecting with people so hit that link
down below in the description box and
check out your reviews calm today we're
on it don't forget to check out the real
rejects follow us there the real rejects
do it the real rejects
[Music]
I see God why I've seen men build
weapons that I couldn't even imagine
I've seen aliens drop from the sky yeah
[Music]
is that line in the movie idly he says
that in the film
[Music]
[Music]
I never freeze okay
it's doing a pretty good job so far not
really ruining antic it feels a lot more
contained that has bothered me to Peru
then
[Music]
I waited my entire life for this
what happens now
see this this is too much
[Music]
yeah okay there are some things in here
that ruin too much for me because
because it's these specific moments that
ruin it for us like okay well I know
what's going to happen yeah
[Music]
so was it the second trailer where they
use around the jewels then now is the
teaser trailer uh which really ruins the
claw getting broken out yeah yeah yeah
that's the mid the midpoint of this
lengthy film the middle of this year is
when claw is captured that's the way to
save the cat be chica is the midpoint is
like the characters either they fail but
it's really a blessing in disguise or
they get what they want but it's really
not what they think it's gonna turn out
to be and the main point here is their
mission that black panther sets out on
is to capture claw and they do that and
they have him in custody but the
trailers clearly show you that Michael B
Jordan kill monger breaks him out I
think like a couple trailers show you
that so that scene lost some of its
intensity for me when the first time I
watch it cuz I'm like well I know closet
and get out of here yesterday fine I was
I'm gonna be brought to a condo by Black
Panther at least yeah there's so much
about we're gonna get claw
who's gonna get claw yeah and yeah I can
imagine that hampering especially if you
remember that moment from this trailer
although I do think that it does a good
job of kind of hiding where things are
gonna pop up some of the time there was
still a lot of parts of the movie that I
didn't even know we're gonna be there I
mean one thing that I thought this
trailer did pretty well at kind of
disguising actually because if you
really pay attention they show a shot of
him of Eric he'll monger talking in the
room or the black panther flowers are
the shot in that same room where
everything is on fire but I didn't put
two and two together when I saw the
trailer yeah that oh he's gonna burn
that room down he's gonna burn all the
flowers I didn't even think about that
when I was watching the movie so that's
a good disguise of what the movie but
this trailer does because it doesn't
actually ruin a big plot point of the
film yeah I think this is pretty good at
taking themes and taking images
indicative of those themes and throwing
them at you yeah yeah and I mean you
don't know what the purple flowers are
but at the same time just watching these
couple scenes yeah you don't really know
what the context is you just know it's
great it does ruin quite a bit I think
in terms of arid kill monger we all knew
it was coming well I knew it was coming
that he was gonna be black panther it
was pretty obviously was gonna be black
panther because in this scene especially
when he has the
Liss on because in the movie when Sheree
is showing the two new suits he's a
first looks up a necklace that kill
mongers rockin yeah and the second I saw
it I was like oh kill mongers kill
mongers gonna take that one because I
saw in the trailer he's rockin it then
he transforms into it and you could see
that the people behind him are under his
command and Black Panthers approaching
him immediately I just knew okay he's
gonna win he's gonna become king of
Wakanda for a bit before a black panther
decides to rise up again and fight him
and his crazy finale I felt like that
gif that gave away a little too much the
movie was still intense the movie was
still exciting I was so gripped when I
was watching it both times I've seen it
but I do feel that this parts of the
trailer gave away a lot of like oh I
know what's gonna happen though you know
details in the movie but it still does
give away you know what's gonna happen
you know they're gonna get into that big
five buy the trains like all that I was
just waiting for to happen because the
trailer showed me yeah and that's I
guess that's part of the trouble is that
you don't get to see kill Munger in his
black panther suit until deep into the
movie when a lot has happened and I get
why they want to tease that at the same
time yeah it does leave you going with
that moment good also I mean if you look
close like Daniel kouya standing right
next to me I never realized the first
time but if you pay close attention I
mean that whole storyline gonna be
pretty apparent to you and one thing I
gotta kind of criticize the trailers on
a little bit like all the main trailers
is they rely heavily on like the kind of
RMB rap type of music and the trailers
yeah there's some of that in the movie
there's some well yeah it doesn't
necessarily miscommunicate the tone of
the film I don't think it completely
represents it either I guess so yeah I
mean this the movie has a nice blend of
I feel like we yeah we got with the
movie what we wish they'd put in the
trailers which was you know they have so
much of that percussive sort of tribal
sounding music that I wish had shown up
a little bit I don't think it's bad to
use some of the more modern poppy tunes
I don't know if this is one of the
tracks from the album but that sounds
like Vince staples and I know he's on
the Black Panthers soundtrack and I know
that you know Top Dawg entertainment put
that together it's kind of a big deal
that they did that I can't fault them
for doing it at the same time I've heard
complaints about it I would have liked
to have seen more of the score itself
pop up yeah for to give us a hint of
that because there is some of that too
some of that score is traditional and
then you'll have beats drop in over it
you know and that splits the difference
but yeah yeah maybe would have liked a
little more of that because I remember
one of my favorite times I heard that
the music in the film itself is during
the finale when Sheree and Nakia are
they dawn their costumes and they're
coming up onto the field and you hear
the African tribal music and I was like
what's interesting about this trailer is
it doesn't spoil the movie in a way
where it's like you watch the trailer
and you go I know exactly everything
that's gonna happen in this movie I know
exactly everything that's gonna play out
not at all I don't it doesn't at the
same time though it was that thing that
when I was watching the film if I was
ever like not fully 100% there and my
mind was just went a little bit forward
in time as to what could happen I was
always able to think of a moment in the
trailer that would give it away cuz
there's that whole thing with a CO a I
have to standby kill monger sigh cuz
he's king then I remembered wait a
minute the trailer showed you that
moment when it all the warders the
female orders of a Conda stand against
and I'm like it's gonna happen at that
scene well that's so fascinating about
trailers in general is like what moments
they show you and how those moments
register in your head because sometimes
you can see an image and it just as part
of a montage of move
sometimes you don't think too hard about
the context or what's going on with it
what's fascinating at the movie itself
is kill mongers we've talked about it
and the spoiler one he's not really in
it the first like hour hour 10 minutes
of the mood really build them up and I
think that's why the these trailers gave
me the one concern of how are you gonna
implement claw and kill monger into this
one film because it looks like they're
both in it throughout when really that's
not the film itself so I think that's a
good misdirection of what the trailers
did not really showing you exactly cuz
there's so much details to the
storylines of so many of these
characters like you don't really get to
tell a storyline in this trailer it
gives away some plot points in terms of
the action set-pieces but there's so
much details in all the people's
storylines that are not revealed in the
trailers that I still respect it for
it's like yeah did something to make
that the Cho's make some stuff a little
predictable or especially in the finale
definitely however looking back on it
I'm like I might've been able to predict
some of this stuff even if I hadn't seen
the trailer again I think this trailer
does a good job of giving you the themes
hinting at the major plot elements but
also not giving you too much context not
showing you too much out of any one
moment so that when they pop up in the
movie there's more stuff around all of
them doesn't ever explain fully any one
thing in this trailer and I appreciate
it for that it's a lot of world-building
it's a lot of mood and tone and you know
the different juxtapositions of
characters yeah actually you know what
are you good it's a first rate visit
that we've done well we're like I feel
like there's gonna be stuff you can
complain about in any and all trailers
but as far as the ones we've looked at
so far yeah I think this is pretty solid
Matt the spider-man homecoming will
probably stick to more older films still
if you just thought it'd be fun to check
out Black Panther right now since we've
been talking a lot about it this weekend
anyway guys thanks for tuning in you
guys can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell to get
notified every time one of our videos is
up and make sure to check us out on
viewer reviews.com sign up today people
we're on it now so check it out right